over the Gaza Strip meanwhile we have
the Israeli Army saying that its
soldiers are in full control of all
communities along the border with Gaza
bodies are being recovered in several
kibuts that are close to the Border
after Hamas launched that surprise
attack on Saturday let's speak now to
alzer's Charles statford he's in kafar
AAR in southern Israel that's one of
those areas that the Israeli Army has
just been into and cleared of Hamas
Fighters tell us the scene there
Charles yes that's right Laura the
Israeli military telling us that there
was fighting up until the early hours of
this morning in this Village a village
that basically sits pretty much directly
on the Gaza border you can see the fence
that runs on the western side of the
village and there's basically a big hole
in it where it has been breached there
are bodies is all over the village what
looked to be Hamas or Palestinian
Fighters now bloated by the Sun and lots
of civilians as well many of those
civilians still in the homes in which
they were killed the Israeli military
saying that there were lots of foreign
workers as well they believe were also
killed in this attack many of the homes
completely destroyed what's so shocking
is that you know people's lives people's
belongings are spread out across you
know uh that their lawns uh where
they've been blown out from these houses
as as they've been hit by explosives
that breach that I talked about is one
of dozens according to the military the
Israeli military these gaps where Hamas
Fighters came through very interesting
also to see one of these paragliders a
destroyed paraglider there in and
amongst the rubble also which the
Israeli military say was used by Hamas
to to cross into this Village you
mentioned that the military are saying
that they have now full control of kafar
AAR and Villages and towns close to the
Gaza border yes that might be the case
but they are also warning that they
believe there still could be Hamas
Fighters Palestinian Fighters still at
large hiding in the countryside in this
area and interestingly it was about an
hour ago we're hearing reports that we
can't confirm of an incident
of suggesting that there was ongoing
fighting around the village of nazim um
which is to directly to the north of the
Gaza Strip in terms of civilians in this
area absolutely no civilians left in
kafar razar whatsoever those that
weren't killed have have left but um
we've been in contact with somebody that
lived through that nightmare for hours
describing how terrified she was hiding
in her home massive amount of milit here
as you can imagine we've seen tanks
we've seen
apcs there's been both outgoing and
incoming shelling as well in the last
few minutes we had uh Rockets fired out
of Gaza that were intercepted behind me
we believed by the Iron Dome we also
hearing what sound to be either very
large artillery pieces or Israeli tanks
that are firing towards Gaza there is
the constant sound of drones above
the military here say they control of
this place but the scenes are utterly
shocking and the situation remains very
fluid and tense absolutely I mean as the
cameras as the media enters these areas
where the uh Hamas Fighters launched
their unprecedented surprise attack in
the early hours of Saturday
morning when Israelis see these pictures
of these small
areas there with people just living in
their houses they're going to be shocked
aren't they they've never seen these
kind of images in Israel
before no this is it I mean Israel is in
a State of Shock of course Gaza is in a
terrible State of Shock you know 2.3
million people being bombed left right
and Center in retribution for these
attacks but yes talking about Israel the
people here are in shock and angry as
well we spoke we were in stot which is a
town close to the right pretty much on
the Gaza border about 2 three k from the
Gaza border further to the north from
here earlier this morning and we spoke
to a man who was shockingly candid in
the language he was using he was like
we've got to go in and we've got to kill
them and he wasn't specific either he
wasn't specifically talking about Hamas
he was that angry you got a sense that
he was blaming the Palestinian people as
well and that of course is what is so
dangerous about this it fuels so much
hate he's like we've got to kill them
we've got to stop their water we've got
to stop their electricity we've got to
stop their power we've got to beat them
we can never allow this to happen again
so voices like that coming out of Israel
are perhaps not surprising but are of
great concern because this has done huge
damage to any kind of potential you know
peace eventual peace between Israel and
Palestine indeed Charles traford
bringing us those scenes from kafar AAR
on the border with Gaza in southern
Israel thanks very much
Charles well there